hey you guys what's going on it's
another movie retrospective and we're
talking about more Universal monsters
you guys are like so excited about these
going back to the classics this one got
voted on right
yes it did yeah yeah yeah and I had
actually been wanting to do this one for
a long time because I haven't seen it
weirdly because the sequel to this uh
you know which is what was it called
revenge of the creature that was on
Mystery Science Theater so I've actually
seen the the uh sequel to this like more
than I've seen the actual one so I was
excited to go back and watch the action
first one it's not bad I mean it's not
as good as the first one okay but and
there's a third one too which I had
forgotten about it and like the third
one I haven't seen but it looks kind of
terrible from like clips of it
you know this one is good for the time
um
not only a couple things have aged well
in it if you ask me but I can see why
it's classic
I mean I kind of feel like the thing
about this one I love this movie
honestly um the best thing about it um
is the monster and like the suit you
know what I mean like that still looks
great I feel like the underwater action
shots yeah I think that's kind of where
this movie really shines uh you know
more than anything the thing about it is
I kind of feel like by this point
because Creature from the Black Lagoon
came out in 1954 uh you know which is
considerably later than a lot of like
Universal monsters Heyday you know what
I mean this was like the First new
monster they'd introduced the thing
about it was that all the old school
monsters you know like Frankenstein and
Dracula and the Wolfman and the mummy
and all that kind of stuff
um you know nobody was going to see like
throughout the 1940s and stuff nobody
was really going to see those monsters
at least in like a serious horror movie
context like it seemed like the only
movies that were coming out that were
doing any business at that time were
ones that were like funny like Abbott
and Costello Meet whoever so they were
riffing on the classics right and that's
what I mean so like like when the 50s
came along obviously anybody that knows
anything about
film history in the United States it's
like obviously the 50s was all about
monster movies and sci-fi so this was
Universal's attempt to do something more
along those lines so they did actually
like introduce a new monster which
quickly kind of became as iconic as the
old ones had but I mean the thing about
this like the guy that had the idea for
it I guess he had the idea for it like
way back in the early 1940s he was
talking to
um I think it was somebody that was
working on Citizen Kane and he was
talking to like this cinematographer and
the cinematographer was from Mexico and
he said he was talking something about
like some story in the Amazon about like
a half man half fish person or something
like that so there was like some kind of
urban legend or some kind of like you
know mythology about it and the guy was
like oh that's like kind of a cool idea
so like many years later when he got
approached by Universal and they were
asking him hey can you come up with like
a monster movie sci-fi kind of mashup
thing he remembered that and he wrote a
story that I think was called the sea
monster and then it went through a
couple different iterations of that and
they finally filmed it as like Creature
from the Black Lagoon so you know the
story of this one is like pretty simple
it's like pretty straightforward you got
kind of like at the very beginning you
have like an archaeologist type dude and
he finds this sort of like fossilized
claw of what looks like a half fish half
man pretty much and you know thinking
that it was like some extinct animal
that is not around anymore he's like we
need to go like find the rest of this
fossil so we need to go down to the
Amazon so him and like a bunch of uh
kind of interchangeable white dudes I
kind of all look to say everybody looked
the same in these bookies yeah I was
like watching um if you guys don't know
about uh what's that channel called this
like count wolf feeler or whatever like
that dude's like super funny and he did
a um a breakdown of this too and he said
the two main guys in it he couldn't tell
them apart so he's like the whole love
triangle thing like with them and and
Julia Julia Adams like the hot chick in
the White swimsuit like he was just kind
of like so I was like weirded out by
this whole thing because I couldn't tell
one from the other yeah well it's it's
shot in black and white they're all
basically wearing the same style of
clothing they have the same voice yeah a
lot of them did and they're the acting
styles were the same that they that they
taught these guys and they are all
speaking basically kind of like
transatlantic or it's stage acting so
they all end up being the same guy
pretty much yeah yeah I mean they do
kind of look a little bit different yeah
the only guy that isn't the same guy is
the Mexican guy the guy the guy captain
in the boat
who was also in the sequel he's great
actually but if you go look in a lot of
these 50s movies even like the thing
from another world or the original thing
the the the dudes are all kind of like
carbon copies of each other and I think
it has to do with the fact that it's
shot in black and white they're wearing
similar clothes and they're all using
kind of that same announcer's voice
yeah they all they definitely had a
tight same yeah like 50s white dudes and
in movies always they had a tight
there's a type that they always put in
there like the authoritative right white
dudes that were they were official white
dudes like official official white dudes
there's only like three or four
different models but they all look alike
too they all wore the same clothes you
know a lot of times so I could well have
a lot of individual personality right
on-screen personality like the leading
man is always the same [ __ ] dude I
mean it might as well be might as well
it might as well be the same dude
um they just really had they hadn't
really perfected the the craft of movie
making yet to make something with a
bunch of interesting compelling
characters yeah there are a few
exceptions
when it came to when it came when it
comes to sci-fi horror
um
uh [ __ ] uh War of the Worlds okay
pretty much every but that was not black
and white but every character in that
was distinct yeah and then uh them with
the with the ants yeah pretty distinct
you can see how them
and the Creature from the Black Lagoon
influenced alien and Aliens a lot yeah
big time you know um
I think I think uh Cameron was making
classic monster movies but then just
updating them you know when he did when
he did aliens and then Ridley Scott is
trying to perfect 50s monster movies in
space too he's trying to make it
realistic you know
uh with real people in it not archetypes
stage yeah that's actually a good point
because I kind of feel like a lot of 50
Sci-Fi movies like yeah they weren't so
much characters as Architects they're
archetypes yeah like you know right and
really Scott blew it out of the water
with alien one all of a sudden it's real
people real working people in space
like truckers or
or they're like Merchant Marines on the
ocean but it's men and women and uh
different socioeconomic classes you have
the enlisted and the officers and
there's tensions kind of between them
and corporate culture but they're not
acting they're just kind of a lot of
that [ __ ] it was was ad-libbed and they
were just being regular people in there
which is very different from a well
classic like I said I think that was
kind of more of like a 60s development
like 60s and onward with like you know
kind of more of a like a cinema verite
or like a more you know naturalistic
filmmaking style whereas prior to that I
feel like it was much more still like
hold over from stagey like you know it's
this is obviously not reality so it's
like a lot more like it's real almost
kind of like fictional yeah theoretical
but they were fictionalized and art yeah
archetypical and stylized right and you
know and that goes on to original Star
Trek series was like that it was a
mixture it was cool you could relate to
the people but it was still very
stylized you know the acting
um I remember being a kid you know my
dad took me to see uh the the very first
alien and I'd never really seen a movie
like that I was young I hadn't seen many
movies but on television there weren't
any movies like that it was like
watching reality TV because their acting
styles were not stylized it was like you
were watching something really happening
and that really drew the audience into
it you could relate to these characters
because they were like you type of Deal
or they were like people you knew when
you were a kid you're like this is
really happening
these movies are a good example of
stylized
theater being shot on film it's very
stagey old-fashioned stagey you know
which uh it's gonna give a certain kind
of tone and one of them and and it tends
to be kind of Bleak you know not Bleak
what's a good not a lot of emotion to it
you don't really relate to these people
and I don't really think I don't really
think the audiences of the time related
to the people I think they related more
to the monsters well the thing about
this one too because and I what I was
going to say when you were talking about
this movie being a big influence on you
know James Cameron or like later monster
movies was that ironically well I don't
know if it's ironically but Creature
from the Black Lagoon
um they basically based it on Beauty and
the Beast or King Kong or kind of like a
template like that because you do I mean
in this one you can even though it's not
explicitly spelled out in the movie The
humans are the bad guys yeah really I
mean they didn't ask they're not like
portrayed that way yeah like the
creature was just mine in his own
beeswax in his little black lagoon
um you know had that scientist not found
that fossil and said hey we're gonna go
down there's Lagoon or like find this
other find the rest of this fossil and
then they found the living one and then
they got all head up because they're
like oh my God we gotta capture this
because nobody will believe us and we're
gonna take it back and then they start
like poisoning the [ __ ] water like
blowing [ __ ] up and everything like that
and yeah and he's just like dude I was
I'm just like swimming here is that okay
with you or like I said so it wasn't
like real explicit but the more you
watch the movie you're like yeah the
people are the bad guys yeah there was
one guy in there that tried to stop it
at the end yeah yeah no no stop shooting
and they were gonna shoot him in the
back while he was running yeah they're
like dude now let him go you know yeah
because that one blonde guy was like a
was a [ __ ] nut yeah the one the one
slightly let the one slightly different
looking guy and in typical
1950s actually pre and it went all the
way back to the 30s too the monsters for
some reason attracted to the woman and
would you look at the difference between
the damn Fish Man and the woman he would
think that she was disgusting yeah I
mean she that fish man wouldn't dig that
I don't know man because I mean
she wasn't that cute
guiller Del Toro I mean most of you guys
know but like um he had been wanting to
make Creature from the Black Lagoon for
a really long time like do a remake of
it and he loved that movie so much and
then like it kept falling through and
kept falling through because you know
Dark Universe and all that kind of stuff
and then he just didn't do it he said
[ __ ] it I'm just gonna make my own story
that's sort of like that so he made the
shape of water uh and that and won an
Oscar but that's essentially what it
would have been like if the fish man uh
you know got captured and then like a
human woman fell in love with him and he
fell in love with her so they actually
like have a relationship like the fish
man and the woman so um you know so
that's what would have happened but it
was his own take on creature in the
black Lune it's actually very good if
you haven't seen it's not a horror movie
exactly but um it has like horror
elements to it but it's really good I
did a review of it a little while back
it came out what 2018 2019 something
like that but uh but yeah so a
interesting thing too about like the one
of the guy that played like the the
darker-haired uh you know generic white
man yeah that guy Richard Carlson he was
in a ton of stuff he was also uh a
writer like a screenwriter and I've been
doing you know that Boris Karloff
Thriller series and he wrote some
episodes of that and he was like in it
as as well because I was like when I
cross-referenced I was like oh my God
that was the guy from creatures in the
Black Lagoon so it's like you always
kind of see like the same people turning
up like that and like I said Julia Adams
was like super super hot in this but oh
and Whit Bissell was in it too and he
was in a bunch of those 50s I think he
was a um he was in I was a teenage
werewolf was he and I was a teenage
werewolf yeah he was one he was in one
of those but um yeah he was in all that
kind of he always played like the same
kind of part but yeah so basically you
know they they just go down to the
Amazon they find this creature the
blonde guy is basically like we need to
capture this creature and like get him
so the rest of the movie is them trying
to capture the creature the creature
falling in love with the human woman and
you know essentially then like after
um you know the the actually the um the
creature tries to keep them from leaving
the Lagoon because so he's smart like he
seems to have like kind of human
intelligence because once he figures out
that um you know that they want to go
back and like bring more people there
like and oh they're gonna [ __ ] it up
even worse like he's like well you guys
can't leave so he just like tries to
like block them into the Lagoon like
they do get out but he does try to like
prevent them from leaving which I was
like oh okay so he's not that dumb but
yeah so the thing about it is that I
mean I still think I love the monster
design okay on this and we were talking
about it because I had forgotten like
how this is made but um they were
talking about when they first made the
the costume they were gonna try and put
you know like an oxygen tank or some
kind of thing where like the dude could
breathe they figured out they couldn't
do it because it would look stupid right
so uh they didn't uh so the guy it's two
different guys
um on land uh he's played by a guy named
Ben Chapman and underwater probably more
famously he's played by a stuntman Rigo
Browning and who is actually still alive
and he does horicons um I've seen him at
a couple horicons so he's still out
there like you know doing the Gillman
thing which is like really really cool
but yeah he would um he would just hold
his breath now they said that sometimes
he would hold his breath for four
minutes which
um he's like well he's like well you
could technically maybe hold your breath
for four minutes like if you weren't
doing anything like if you were just
sitting there because there were some
shots of that yeah but he's like if
you're swimming around and stuff maybe
two minutes tops that's about all he
could do so anytime you see the Gill man
swimming around underwater he doesn't
have a tank he doesn't have nothing
that's just like a dude dude in a suit
swimming around yeah I didn't see any
bubbles so I was and especially like
toward because we were like talking
about like toward the end with those
underwater fight scenes like with him
fighting the dudes under I'm like holy
crap that's amazing if that dude is just
like [ __ ] yeah holding his breath
like that that's what shines in this
movie is the underwater big time Big
Time it looks like something okay a lot
of times in the 50s movies it's just
kind of real static [ __ ] like
lumbering monster suits this looks fast
yeah and it's really good it looks it
looks dangerous it looks like they
really are fighting then you got you got
scuba divers they're going pretty fast
and they're got uh spear guns and [ __ ]
trying to fight him and they're they're
going underneath stuff it's good and it
is very good it's a very well edited and
acted out action scenes yeah the only
thing the only scenes I've ever seen
like this in the 50s would be like them
when the uh when the Army was fighting
the ants under in the in in the flood
control system underneath la
and also when uh yeah that scene I think
was under la
those dudes some of those dudes really
knew how to handle weapons and guys in
close combat with Thompson submachine
guns against giant ants you could buy it
and that's really kind of where they
went with aliens you know with the the
colonial Space Marines fighting the
things this also kinda
kind of brings in aliens or alien the
costume looks really good and as far as
I know that costume probably was not
topped until alien
that looks real credible like that it
looks like a real creature it looks like
a real animal pretty real pretty yeah I
mean like as far as especially as far as
like the the standards of the 50s or the
50s at the time it's pretty real which
you know most of the monsters in the 50s
looked pretty generous right I'm trying
to think of any other movie after that
that had a realistic full body suit
monster
alien probably the next one yeah it's
like really hard to think of one I mean
I'm sure there is one that we're
forgetting but I mean that God damn that
[ __ ] Gilman suit is so good it looks
so good well I'm not talking about a
zombie or anything like that I'm talking
about a full body dude in a monster like
a monster monster suit and I can't think
of anything after this right up until
alien one alien yeah so that's like more
than 20 years yeah because I remember
being a kid in the 70s mid 70s
and the the only
monster suit that impressed impressed me
up until that time was the creature for
the Black Lagoon there wasn't anything
else then alien came out it was 79 and I
was just like whoa you know it just
totally changed the paradigm
because think about it man the the Apes
from Planet of the Apes didn't look real
no I mean they looked good I'm not
saying they didn't look good but they
didn't look like that I didn't really
think that that was a real eight person
no you know that was a dude in a math
this thing you know what I mean you know
it's a guy and I'm basically a souped-up
wetsuit
but it you can buy it especially in the
50s context just think about it like I'm
I'm usually a big advocate of like oh
don't show your monster that much and
stuff like that but I'll make an
exception for this movie because that's
[ __ ] suit looks so good and they show
it like in lots of different contexts
he's walking around on land he's
swimming around in the water they show
him like being still they show them
really close up the first time they show
it a hand comes up out of the water and
grabs some rocks and you go damn that
hand looks good it's got webbed fingers
on it it looks it looks fantastic it
looked like the real aquatic Monster
Hand and so I'm glad that they showed it
as much as they did and got the kind of
shots that they got they're real action
shots especially underwater shots it
looks great those are amazing they look
great I mean he's swimming in that suit
and hold this breath yeah and it looks
like something real I mean it was creepy
when I was a kid I was seeing on
television like man that's [ __ ]
creepy looking that thing I even like
the shots of him where they just show
him and he's like under the water like
looking up at the boat like from like in
the right in the weeds or whatever
that's like that's really creepy looking
goggle fish eyes fisheye looking things
now it's got looked like real glass eyes
in it so I guess you could see through
him yeah he could see well mostly he
said he could mostly see like a friend
he didn't really have any peripheral
vision the only thing before alien one
that came out that could rival that
costume would be like the slee Stacks
from um yeah Land of the Lost yeah
everything else [ __ ] sucked and this
I went back and looked at the sleet
stacks and for the time they for
television they looked I mean for his
low budget TV show was they were
actually way better than they had
anyways to be yeah they're pretty good
especially the Enoch one the one that
could talk the brown one yeah yeah yeah
he looked better
um so like creature from Black Lagoon
and the sleestax that'd be about it can
we talk about let's let's talk a little
bit about this because I feel like maybe
a lot of people don't know this little
bit of horror trivia
so the head of the Gillman costume
was designed by a woman named Millicent
Patrick now she was a one of the first
female Disney animators she worked on
Fantasia uh she worked on but she worked
on like a bunch of stuff and actually
she went on and worked on a bunch of 50
sci-fi but she did like some of the
masks and the mole people and she worked
on The Meta Luna guy from like this
island Earth all this kind of stuff so
she did the head for the creature from
she sculpted it she did like the design
and everything like that now when the
movie was first coming out because she
was like very young and very pretty uh
they made her part of the marketing
materials like you know Beauty made the
Beast all this other kind of stuff and
she went on a tour right like with the
her drawings of the head and everything
so she was doing that and then behind
her back Universal Studios and the
makeup artist who was also working on
the Gilman suit uh whose name I know but
I'm not gonna say it because he's
because he's an [ __ ] but he basically
went to Universal and cried because he
didn't want her to get the credit for
Designing the head even though she did
so Universal said okay so they changed
all the marketing to Beauty lives with
the Beast rather than Beauty made the
Beast which is what it was originally
and they basically took her name off the
[ __ ] and then when she got back to LA
after the tour they fired her damn at
his insistence because he was so
butthurt that she had done the head and
he wanted the credit for it and he took
credit for it uh for a long time I don't
think they actually figured out that she
had actually made it until the 2000s or
later so I was like wow so she never got
another job what a shitty dude yeah like
after that
um she basically went back into like
acting and like minor acting and
modeling she didn't uh work again like I
said she did do some minor stuff on mole
people but I think mole people was
before this now that I'm thinking about
it but at least she's getting credit now
but it's like I was like wow that was
like really really shitty that was
really shitty that that dude did that
but uh but yeah everybody knows now but
you know it's a little too late to help
her any but yeah there's that uh because
like I said this the Gillman costume is
like [ __ ] iconic and it's easily the
best monster of the 50s I wonder if it's
still around
oh I don't know Somebody's gotta have
that I mean I wouldn't think that they
would have gotten rid of and I don't
know if they had more than one I think
they just had several of I mean you
would think that they would have several
that's what they would usually do just
in case something goes wrong in case
something goes wrong and I'm not really
sure because it was two guys playing it
I'm not really sure if they were both
wearing the same suit right you know
what I mean because maybe they had to
have adjustments maybe once like
slightly different size or something
like that also another thing I didn't
know about Creature from the Black
Lagoon was that it was originally shot
to be shown in 3D
um but that makes sense why some of the
stuff is coming straight in right right
right yeah it's like I didn't really
notice it that much when I was watching
it but then when I looked it up I was
like oh yeah like I remembered some kind
of stuff the thing about it though is
like they were thinking about
um because I think a year prior they had
done well I think it was House of Wax
maybe and that was like 3D and that was
kind of a big hit so they were like oh
we need to do a 3D one too but then by
the time it was coming out 3D was kind
of fizzling out a little bit and so
really only the really big like Big City
theaters got the 3D like pretty much
everybody else in the country saw it in
2D and honestly like for a long time
even when they tried to like release it
um because I think it had the gray
filter like they do 3D nowadays it
didn't have like the black and the black
and blue thing or not black and blue red
and blue yeah what was it wasn't color
right yeah so but for a long time like
they tried to release different versions
of it in 3D but it's like they could
never get it to line up right and it was
all this other kind of [ __ ] so I don't
know like maybe you can get it now like
where you can watch it watch it the way
it's supposed to be watched but as far
as I know you can't like we every
version I've ever seen is flat so I
didn't even realize that it was supposed
to have been filmed in 3D I don't think
it'd make a big difference I don't think
it would I mean but from what I heard
like at least from people that saw it
back then in 3D because it did show in
some theaters they said it looked
amazing like in 3D but you know but uh I
don't know so because not that many
people got to see it apparently but yeah
so there's
there are certain things that don't hold
up about the movie
um it's got a lot of dialogue in it that
is if you ask me filler oh but that's
real that's awesome pretty much all 50s
monster movies yeah they're just trying
to pad the movie out to get get some
more time out of it and they spend a lot
of time explaining things to you that
you should know or things that aren't
really all that relevant like they even
go get into some subjects like well this
will teach us how animals evolve so we
can learn to evolve ourselves on other
planets when we colonize other planets
that's kind of far thinking
remember that yeah that's right I was
like yeah genetically engineering human
beings so they could yeah they don't
talk about that [ __ ] and that kind of
stuff so uh there was but here's the
deal that's totally relevant to this but
they talked about it they used that as
filler so at least a lot of the padding
and the filling filler is
kind of interesting you know it would
have been that would have been real
interesting in the 50s well and they
were trying to give it like a realistic
and also like a Sci-Fi context just like
oh man that's like think about that
right yeah and that's why we want to
study this monster like so much yeah I
get it
um had it been made later they just
would have edited all that out it had
been straight action through the whole
thing probably would have held up a
little bit better
um but it was just the limitations and
the tastes of the time you know they
were yeah but that's what the audience
expected I think watching these movies I
have a feeling that the audience really
didn't pay too close attention to the
dialogue anyway I think they were
sitting in the theater eating popcorn
[ __ ] yelling probably a little kid
little kids yelling and [ __ ] there's his
way for the monsters show yeah clapping
on them story because they're actually
entertaining if you just watch them like
that too so I kind of think a lot of
dialogue goes in one ear and out the
other I think I mean honestly as long as
you got them and there is a lot of the
monster in this I'm not gonna lie a lot
of the monster is in that and also you
know you get Julia Adams in that
swimsuit so I'm sure that was really
yeah they they make sure you see that
she's well built you know although the
swimming scenes were not her that was a
body double okay she's but uh she's
she's well built good looking woman how
old was she 21. I don't know actually
yeah I think she was just in her 20s
yeah but yeah so you can see how the the
Gillman would be like yeah you know what
I'm saying nice legs she did yeah
although like I said in the swimming
scenes uh that wasn't her that was
somebody else but she I mean they show
her in the bathing suit yeah she's
walking around the boat and stuff so
it's not like it's all body double just
the swimming is the body double
um also this is a fun fact too like all
the underwater stuff was actually filmed
right here in Florida uh in Wakulla
Springs actually which is only about
four hours from here I feel like I think
it's supposed to be the Amazon it is it
is supposed to be the Amazon but um you
know they're not gonna go to the [ __ ]
Amazon in the 50s no and film you
wouldn't want to go there now and film
well that's what I'm saying it would
probably be like two days that's what I
mean it's too dangerous it's just too
expensive it's too much trouble most of
it I mean they filmed a lot of it on
Universal's Backlot like they did with
most of the stuff
um but you know all I think almost all
of it like the outside shots other than
the underwater stuff was filmed in
California but like the underwater stuff
was filmed in Florida and what coolest
brings so you know know there's that too
and actually I didn't know that that was
where they shot it but that's where they
shot it but yeah I think like I said
I kind of feel like
you know like a lot of 50s films it does
have that kind of you know white dude
standing around talking about stuff yeah
but a lot of 50s movies had that yeah um
and at least we're not being racist
we're white people it's just no I'm just
I'm just well no I mean that's they are
there's not really any and honestly at
least this does have like some more
interesting like it has the hot girl and
it also has like the funny boat captain
yeah uh who like I said he's also in the
sequel I don't know if he's in the third
one but I know for sure he's in the
sequel they're just very generic
archetypes they're crazy they're kind of
conformist in the way that where you're
very predictable you know what kind of
characters are going to be in these
movies every one of these movies has the
same assortment of characters the
scientist dude the F the [ __ ] uh the
leading man jock basically yeah uh the
uh the tough guy from the Bronx or
something you know what I mean the
southern guy yeah uh very archetypal
yeah it's all architect and then you got
then you got like the Mexican guy who's
almost usually comedic relief oh sadly
yeah yeah yeah what do you say senor you
know all that kind of stuff you know you
Hamming it up and [ __ ]
um uh the big strong black guy that's
always in there A lot of times it's in
there yeah not this one not this this
one well yeah I mean they do have to
like um who guys who are supposed to be
like you know Amazonian like guides or
whatever at the beginning and they're
not really played as comic relief
although
um they're just basically monster fodder
because they get they're the first ones
that get eaten by the monster you know
which is kind of shitty but you know
it's just it's just the way they wrote
those movies and it was just the way
they were trying to play to certain
demographics of the time and uh the
audience was very different who was
going to see these movies
and you wanted them to play Nationwide
so you had to have like at least one
person from every [ __ ] region uh they
all kind of had to be
understandable to everybody no matter
what region you lived in so it was
basically transatlantic and fake
Southern Accents
um
if they're just real predictable you
guys know 50s movies if you're watching
yeah yeah it's the way they were but
that's the thing I kind of feel like
other than you know that very which like
I said is admittedly a very minor
criticism uh because this movie is not
long so it's not like it drags or
anything like that but um but really the
star of the show here obviously is the
monster the suit looks great they show a
lot of the monsters and the monster is
like the hero he's not the hero because
he kills a lot of people but he's kind
of like a misunderstood like you don't
blame him for killing the people because
like get the [ __ ] out my house it's like
all these people came in and started
[ __ ] up like I said they poisoned the
water like at one point trying to get
him like I don't know if all the fish
died or if they just shoot it was the
first thing they did didn't they shoot
him and then the first thing that
happens to him pretty much probably it
was I was like yeah that sounds about
right he was up on the deck of the boat
and they shot him yeah you know so it's
not you know yeah so the boss was like
dude I'm just I think he was just
standing on a boat like I said he's
looking at the girl standing on the boat
I think they shot him I think that's the
first thing that happened because I mean
the thing about it was like
he just he they did but he was um yeah
he came up and he killed the two guys
the two guys right right he might have
had a prior beef with them we don't know
right we don't know that was like the
first thing and they were invading like
I said he doesn't know he's an animal
yeah so it's like all he sees is like
who the [ __ ] are these [ __ ]
camping out on my [ __ ] it's like
normally nobody's here yeah so so this
is another thing where like in King Kong
this is kind of like man's hubris I
guess like you're wandering into this
place where previously the monster had
lived just minding his own business and
then you blundered in there like trying
to capture him and [ __ ] like that of
course he's gonna fight back you know
what I mean and you know it's not his
fault he fell in love with that girl she
looked hot in that swimsuit and he's
lonely there's not another lady monster
around anywhere it looked like so you
know you can't really blame the guy
but I'm just saying so like at the end
um you know it looks like he dies at the
end but they do kind of like leave it
ambiguous because like I said you know
spoiler alert there is a sequel there's
actually two sequels uh revenge of the
creature which I've seen multiple times
because it was on Mystery Science
Theater it's not bad uh the suit in that
looks better
um Nestor paiva the guy that plays the
um the boat captain he returns uh but
it's like a new story uh the third one
I've seen stills from it or like clips
from it and it looks not that great and
I don't think they use the same suit uh
because the suit looks um significantly
shittier yeah so um I think if it's if
it was the right thing that I was
looking at so I don't know I'm kind of
curious to see it just you know just to
see what it's like but you know but
honestly like the first one is the best
one but the second one's okay too if you
want to go that route although the MST
episode is like a lot funnier probably
than just watching it by itself but yeah
I kind of feel like the the monster is
the main reason to watch this and those
unbelievable like underwater shots like
all the underwater shots are amazing the
underwater fight scenes the underwater
action scenes like you don't even see
[ __ ] that good like nowadays sometimes
you definitely didn't see anything that
good in the 80s no no water shots nope I
mean that legit looked like a dude and a
monster like fighting underwater and
it's just like wasn't I mean it was
really well done yeah really well done
so yeah those are the best parts of the
movie they are yeah I think that's like
definitely the highlights when he's on
land and he's in his lair nah
I don't buy it as much it's because the
way they instructed that actor they
should he's just walking around in a
suit kind of lumbered around that suit
looked pretty flexible
I'd have had a guy who was real
um
good at dance or ballet or like mime
mimery yeah and have him walk like an
animal I mean like okay like in Predator
one the guy who played The Predator was
a big old tall dancer yeah and he made
that movie he made that character
believable the way he's walking and
jumping and you know what I mean you
have to know how to use your body to
become that creature and to me the guy
just looks just kind of like a shambling
kind of a yeah and like I said it was a
different dude yeah he looked a lot more
natural underwater but like I said that
underwater looked great that was a
different dude that was like that played
him like online played him underwater
and the dude that was underwater was
like kind of like an underwater yeah
they needed they needed to do like a
diaper they needed to do like the dude
that played the Predator yeah around in
that thing and you get to see him he
does a cameo at the very end he's the uh
the uh the helicopter pilot the black
guy at the very end when the shit's
blowing up and come to save the to Save
Arnold yeah that's
yeah unfortunately died of AIDS from a
from a blood transfusion yeah he was a
big tall guy he had cancer but yeah
that's the thing well and that's why um
you know the guy um and [ __ ] I can't
remember what his name is right now but
the guy that plays um that played the
fish man and the gay armadel Toro movie
shape of water he played um you know the
Pale Man and Pan's Labyrinth like any
time he played Abe Sapien and Hellboy
like any time you need like a creature
it's that guy and it's kind of the same
kind of thing I don't think that guy's a
dancer but he's like you know he's very
very slim and he's like very good at
like physicality like doing physical
that makes him look like a monster or
make him look like inhuman in a lot of
ways because I'm a character you do and
that's the thing and I like I said I
kind of feel like
you know the underwater scenes with the
Gillman like that definitely looks like
a real creature like a real creature
that could exist like the way he's
moving around because it's very natural
whereas like you said on land it's it's
still good like on land it's still the
suit looks good and everything like that
but it's definitely a man it does suffer
a little bit from that kind of like man
and monster suit yeah thing but not as
bad as like to be hunched over he needs
to have more of a hop more of a hop walk
almost like a bipedal frog or something
some kind of an amphibian kind of a
looking thing something that can jump
from rock to rock could sit the right
way you know yeah maybe it would have
been better to make him not bipedal but
then but then but then like he couldn't
carry the girl around which was a big
part of the market don't over his
shoulder though yeah like it might have
been cooler if he was more like more
like alligator yeah like that maybe
should have shown him climbing up rocks
and sitting up on top of [ __ ] things
jumping off and sitting funny you know
sitting like a frog or something
like a gargoyle yeah that'd have been
cool yeah that have been cool although I
will argue like I said I think the suit
still looks amazing yeah like on land it
still looks good it looks good in every
because I was like really looking at it
like while we were watching the movie
and I was like man that suit's [ __ ]
incredible it's like the attention to
detail the reason why it wasn't really
making sense for me underneath the water
it looked very smooth and fluid it
looked natural but even was walking on
land it's just a man in a suit out ahead
he should have been real fast and agile
you know and going around with rocks and
climbing and jumping and they could have
done that they if they could shoot those
underwater shots they could have shot
stuff above ground and edited it right
kind of like he did with the Predator
you know just having more amphibian and
you just needed the right guy
to become that creature on land some
kind of a acrobat or some kind of a
dancer yeah yeah yeah probably that was
just some dude in a suit yeah well what
are you gonna do like I said I think it
was a stunt man yeah I think it was a
zombie yeah wrong guy
I needed a dancer but yeah well like I
said I don't really know if they thought
about that too much back then because
they were just like well we're just
making a monster it's just a monster
movie they didn't know that like you
know 50 years later like people were
gonna be talking about it so you know
what I mean like this many years later
so you know how like influential it was
so yeah they didn't really think about
it they thought of it more throw away
yeah I don't really blame the stunt man
because [ __ ] it was his Direction that's
What probably what the director told her
to do
he probably could have done you know
better under a different direction too
yeah that's a yeah that's just you know
he's just doing what they're told what
he was told to do yeah like I said they
just probably it's too much like
Frankenstein you have to think too that
like in the 1950s they still weren't
taking horror and sci-fi all that
seriously so it was just kind of like
hey it's just a monster movie like for
the kid you know what I mean right but
you know I mean but they did like to be
fair they did spend like a really long
time making yeah making the suit look
amazing and you know doing those
underwater shots so they did care a
little bit obviously I'm just saying
that maybe they didn't maybe it just
didn't go like that extra yeah the dots
yet you know what I mean you have to
become this creature all the time
yeah you know and it has to in the edit
had to be it looked too slow
too much like Frankenstein
yeah you know but underneath the water
it's fast and agile and it had to be
fast and agile on land
and they did they didn't they didn't ask
him to do that yeah oh well what are you
gonna do yeah I've been using it should
have been using terrain and hiding in
the bushes and jumping that's just a
totally different route than what they
did they just had it out in the open
Chandler walking towards the water
climbing up on the boat they climbed up
on the boat well he was trying to get
the girl you know yeah he's just like
I'll just be taking this boot yeah if
you look and animals don't just so I can
do what that thing did you know I mean
they used terrain and they run over
things and jump and and they should have
had to do that you guys should have done
it although I do think they were trying
to imply that he was partly human too
because like I said he was smart enough
to know how to climb onto the boat he
was smart enough to know how to block
the the Lagoon to keep them from getting
out because he understood that they
would bring more people like if they
left imma come back come back at you
with something
the humans had technology and Firearms
you have to have an advantage for the
monster so to right to give him a chance
and and typically in a good Creature
Feature monster movie now modern one
it's his physicality right speed it can
camouflage that kind of stuff you know
and they could have done it they just
could have edit it a different way
should have done it kind of like
Predator where you see hints of the
motion you don't see him covering a lot
of distance it's in flashes yeah you
chop it up to make it look like damn you
know he went fast right you know
because it's only like two or three
seconds and then they you show it in
slow motion to make you think it's
happening fast see that's how I do
things sometimes
they're real slow all right and it fools
everybody into thinking that it did it
fast see didn't know about that yeah
okay yeah I gotta get out of here
[Laughter]
okay
all right so uh what do you guys think
about Creature from the Black Lagoon
probably the last of the iconic
Universal monster movies and the one
that you know introduced a new one that
hadn't existed before so that was like
kind of neat but yeah so it's on uh 2B
at the moment if you want to watch it
for free also let me know if you've seen
the third one and if it's worth watching
because I've seen the second one and
that one's okay but it's like I don't
know if I should waste time watching the
third one or not because I don't really
hear anything about it so if you've seen
it like let me know if it's worth
watching and I'll I'll look into it
alright so that'll do it for this movie
retrospective we'll see you guys again
on the next one
foreign